[Musica]
[Applauso]
io a cannes nel 2017 non ci sono andato
cannes per una persona come il
sottoscritto che lavora in facebook è
l'evento dell'anno
ogni anno aggiunge c'è il festival della
pubblicità che per una realtà come la
nostra è l'evento un po come gli oscar
sono momento ciò che per antonomasia
raccoglie un po tutto il mondo del
cinema
a cannes è l'appuntamento mondiale è per
tutti coloro che operano nel mondo della
comunicazione della pubblicità ma io non
ci sono andato io non ci sono andate
immagino che molti di voi penseranno ci
sono andato perché era malato in realtà
niente tutto ciò che ci sono andato
perché ero guarito e questo è il motivo
però credo che si faccia un po fatica
con tra le due cose quindi fatemi fare
un passo indietro e arrivare un po alla
volta
a questo punto ora nella zona del 2011
ha quasi per caso mi accorsi di un
gonfiore al capezzolo sinistro
in un primo momento a sottovalutare la
cosa quasi come se fosse un meccanismo
di difesa e non voglio pensarci per due
mesi era proprio agosto quando comincia
a sentire questa questa sensazione e
riuscì ad andare dal mio medico di base
a ottobre quindi andando dal medico di
base mi mandò subito lui stesso a fare
un'ecografia con una certa urgenza e
quello fu il momento in cui la paura mi
precipito addosso
il momento esatto in particolare fu
quando il medico che doveva descrive
milesi letto di quell'esame di quelle
ecografia uscì dalla stanza per
consultarsi con la sua collega e impiega
tre minuti per non dire nulla potrebbe
serve un altro esame occorre vederci
chiaro
dopo di che il sottoscritto un po
risoluto e nel carattere che un po la
caratterizza ha chiesto e non è un
tumore perché si capiva che era qualcosa
di non positivo ed è chiaro che in quel
momento il senso di disorientamento
stava prendendo il possesso di me e il
problema iniziava ad essere chiaro
dall'altra parte però non era chiara la
soluzione è la notizia
siamo arrivata poi concretamente con un
ago aspirato aveva un tumore alla
mammella e anche a quel punto il
problema era molto chiaro ma la
strategia sempre meno ea quel punto per
me per come sono fatto la paura ha
cominciato a crescere inesorabilmente
sempre più velocemente
il mio problema che non ne sapeva
abbastanza non comprendevo e avevo paura
guardavo i miei figli ai tempi di 15
anni e dovesse essere sincero tristezza
va da sé ma lacrime mi assalivano
costantemente cercavo un modo un metodo
per capire come avrei potuto combattere
eppure niente ero completamente
disorientato come quando si guarda un po
il cielo nell'emisfero sud e non si
riconosce nessuna costellazione avevo
bisogno di fare domande e chiedere
capire avevo bisogno di un metodo e per
questa inizia a cercare ostinatamente
cercando diciamo medici chirurghi
diciamo che quella ricerca terminò
quando trovai una persona il dottor
agresti e i tempi alla primaria di
senologia istituto di tumori di milano
che diciamo mi fece un po svoltare in
realtà non fece niente di particolare
dottor agresti fece semplicemente tre
cose innanzitutto fu molto chiaro mi
spiega semplicemente in parole semplici
quale fosse la situazione quale fosse lo
scenario di fronte a me e altrettante il
fatto di essere un po della storia dalla
parte sbagliata della statistica il
fatto di essere uno su cento di che si
ammala di tumore al seno non era
certamente essere una maggioranza anzi
eri proprio una minoranza però quello
ero io
la seconda quella di essere molto
assertivo direttivo che per come sono
fatto anche una volta io e qualche cosa
che apprezzo e dall'altra parte però fu
un passaggio importante perché mi indicò
un piano indica una strada e mi scrisse
una strategia un cronoprogramma
anche perché tendo a pensare che nei
momenti in cui le persone in difficoltà
non hanno bisogno di essere incoraggiate
sia anche quello ma certamente hanno
bisogno soprattutto in quel momento di
disorientamento
sentirsi dire che cosa fare dall'altra
parte
terzo punto era era un qualche cosa che
non aveva a che fare con le parole
riuscì a trasmettermi la diciamo questa
cosa in un modo diverso e con la sua
presenza con il suo sguardo è
confrontati a diciamo che non era una
conoscenza specifica non una competenza
ma piuttosto un abilità aveva più a che
fare con il modo in cui si fanno le cose
più che nel fare certe cose ha di fronte
a me c'era una persona non soltanto un
medico che in modo diretto competente
disponibile era diventato per me
certamente un punto di riferimento e a
questo punto si il cero nell'emisfero
sud cominciava ad avere certamente un po
più di chiarezza e cominciavano a
vedersi orione l'orsa maggiore la stella
polare le cose diciamo stavano
cominciando a tornare a tornare nel loro
ordine
certamente la paura non esisteva più
per come vero descritta c'era una paura
derivante ancora da quello che doveva
succedere da quello che era poi
l'operazione ma certamente la persona
aveva rimosso tantissime angosce
tantissima paura ora è andato
sicuramente tutto bene ed è questa una
frase che declina dal futuro ce la siamo
sentita ripetere molto spesso negli
ultimi mesi però nulla succede per caso
credo che le cose hanno più probabilità
di andare bene quando queste seguono un
certo piano io personalmente non mi sono
mai vergognato di condividere il mio
tumore alla mia malattia e per questo
lohan che ha avuto la possibilità di
farlo pubblicamente l'ho fatto
condividendo anzi pensando quelli che
sono stati i miei momenti di difficoltà
e come in quel momento di malattia o di
una malattia grave
la sensazione è quella di essere soli io
mi ricordo che nonostante avessi fianco
a me tantissime persone mia moglie in
primis che mi ha aiutato tantissimo
pensi che ma per creata e quindi la
solitudine è qualche cosa che certamente
ti avvolge ti un po prime
quando però senti parlare o sento
parlare di altre persone che erano tra
insomma ha vissuto lo stesso tipo di
situazione ecco quella solitudine un po
era data via ed è il motivo per il quale
ho pensato che condividere questa questa
esperienza fosse un buon modo per creare
valore anche per altri soprattutto per
le persone in maggiore difficoltà per
questo raccontato la mia malattia
per questo raccontato di come ne sono
uscito e anche di come effettivamente
dopo cinque anni di terapia a terapia
con 1825 pastiglie prese appunto per
cinque anni tutti in un giorno sono
riuscito a diciamo ad uscirne e ad avere
diciamo una possibilità di recupero
diciamo che però è il mio messaggio
principale a che fare con qualche cosa
che però io definisco un effetto
collaterale che in poi il motivo per il
quale non sono andato a canna
quel giorno la malattia mi ha fatto
realizzare quanto lo sport sia
importante quanto possa essere
effettivamente un generatore di
benessere
io certo avevo fatto da giovane
moltissimo sport ho fatto per dieci anni
noto agonistico dopo di che è entrata
nel mondo del lavoro per oltre dieci
anni il lavoro aveva preso il
sopravvento e preso diciamo le priorità
della mia vita però da allora da che
appunto sono guarito non c'è stato un
giorno in cui non abbia rinunciato ad
allenarmi ora non mi era mai capitato di
provare su me stesso quanto l'attività
sportiva possa regalarci salute
ottimismo e anche una migliore qualità
della vita
però queste cose che prima forse l'aveva
immaginate sentite raccontare da altre
le voci le rose sicuramente provate
sulla mia pelle
certamente ora posso dirlo con con
certezza non sono più diciamo lo stesso
luca di prima sono un uomo che prima ha
conosciuto la paura poi ha conosciuto un
altro uomo che ne ha ridefinito il
concetto e sono un uomo che ha scelto di
fare tutto ciò che può fare per stare
bene perché sa che il suo star bene è il
miglior regalo per chi vuole bene sono
un uomo che attraversando la paura è
cambiato certamente non migliore non
peggiore
semplicemente diverso